[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance in the wake of last Friday's
terrorist attack by another American
against Americans at an American airport
at least five deadly six wounded guns
gun terrorism a reminder of all the
things getting worse in this country
that Trump will not even think of let
alone act against in defense of the
American people his question would not
be how on earth have we let our country
deteriorate to the point that the last
three high-profile mass public shootings
in this country San Bernardino the
Orlando nightclub the Fort Lauderdale
Airport have been accomplished with
legal weapons and with legal
transportation of those weapons his
question would not be how do we have a
system by which anybody international
terrorist or nondenominational psychotic
who wants to kill a lot of people at an
airport can have the airline essentially
delivered the guns and the ammunition to
them as if they were ordering a pizza
his first question would be in office
his first question will be is it Muslims
his second question would be in office
his second question will be how can he
exploit it to increase his power his
last question would be in office his
last question will be how can we make
sure this latest nightmare does not
infringe upon the holy Second Amendment
the Constitution with all the amendments
is 7820 words law two of its clauses
mentioned an exact value in cash and
merchandise and the word money appears
six times in the Constitution and coin
five times there are 10 references to
taxes 19 times you read duty or duties
the word debt appears seven times five
uses of the word compensation - imports
- exports and the rest of it the non
ownership parts stripped away the rest
of our United States Constitution and
it's amendments reads profit paid
treasury and monuments revenue imposed
excises impost excises credit commerce
bankruptcies securities exclusive right
purchased capitation Commerce revenue
treasury appropriations receipts
expenditures profit emolument credit
gold silver tender payment in posts in
post treasury profit emolument bribery
lands grants forfeiture fines equity
payment
mentions bounties pay obligation
obligations incomes manufacturers sale
pay value owner property property
private property our Constitution is a
property document our Constitution is
about ownership in the Constitution the
words vote votes and voting appear only
37 times the words right and rights 15
times money and concepts concerning
ownership 103 times our Constitution is
first and foremost a property contract
when the government can own and must own
and pay for and what the people can own
and when they must own and pay for it it
is Noble and most of it is held up
flawlessly since 1787 and in some places
it is sublime but it does not read like
the Declaration of Independence its
closest relative is the contract you
sign when you buy a car so isn't it
funny that in the second amendment the
second of all of them ever passed the
one about guns it doesn't say anything
about owning guns a constitution that
actually mentions $10 and then $20 and
yet there isn't one of those ownership
or property or value words in the part
about guns a well-regulated militia
being necessary to the security of a
free State the right of the people to
keep and bear Arms shall not be
infringed which one of those words means
own as opposed to being given possession
of and retain none of them which words
in the part stating that the Second
Amendment is about the well-regulated
militia in a free state which ones are
unclear none of them the Second
Amendment is there to keep state
militias legally it does this by keeping
legal the rights of private citizens to
bear arms for use in a militia the
Second Amendment guarantees the right to
your state National Guard
it doesn't say a thing about prohibiting
gun control the Second Amendment is gun
control it may say you can bear a gun
it may even say you can keep a gun if
you're using it as part of a
well-regulated militia but it does not
say you can own one and if you don't own
that
you're keeping and bearing necessarily
somebody else does on it and by process
of elimination that somebody else has
got to be the government and therefore
the Constitution starts with the idea
that the government controls the guns
all guns and by way the arms mentioned
in the Second Amendment
those presumably are muskets not
repeating rifles not machine guns not
automatic killing devices saying the
founding fathers wanted to protect your
right to own an assault weapon is as
stupid as saying they wanted to protect
your right to own nuclear weapons and we
have a history of government gun control
that stretches back to the 19th century
back to when the musket began the
process of evolving into an Uzi the so
called gunfight at the OK Corral in
Tombstone Arizona on October 26 1881 the
epitome of the Wild West was about gun
control to prevent gun terrorism and
deadly violence it was illegal to carry
a gun in Tombstone and the Clanton's and
the McLaurys were ignoring gun control
and the town marshals the eart brothers
were enforcing gun control of course
what does that matter am an elected
president dog whistle throughout his
campaign to the Second Amendment people
he's claimed he carries a gun at all
times he is fighting to keep a private
bodyguard instead of relying solely on
the Secret Service his son has reported
last weekend in the Washington Post is
advocating for legislation to end the
nine-month waiting period for silencers
on guns and rifles on the Second
Amendment this is settled law the
Supreme Court ruled in the Heller case
in 2008 it doesn't matter if the words
used your keep and bear arms rather than
keep and owned arms or own and bear arms
Supreme Court the Supreme Court is not
the Supreme Being
while some cowardly politicians will
wave the white flag and surrender to the
false god of judicial supremacy
I refuse to light a match to our
Constitution we must resist and reject
judicial tyranny not retreat former
Arkansas governor and frequent
presidential aspirant Mike Huckabee
wrote that we've had too many examples
in recent years of courts and judges
legislating they're not interpreting
what the law says and whether someone
was violated or not in too many
instances they have been actually
legislating by legal decree what they
think the law should be and that I don't
go for speaking the 40th President of
the United States Ronald Reagan they
said it I didn't Owen one more quote
about the Supreme Court and the Second
Amendment the gun lobby's interpretation
of the Second Amendment is one of the
greatest pieces of fraud I repeat the
word fraud on the American people by
special interest groups that I have ever
seen in my lifetime the real purpose of
the Second Amendment was to ensure that
state armies the militia would be
maintained for the defense of the state
the very language of the Second
Amendment refutes any arguments that it
was intended to guarantee every citizen
and unfettered right to any kind of
weapon he or she desires
the writer adding quote the Second
Amendment doesn't guarantee the right to
have firearms at all who wrote that
Warren Berger Chief Justice of the
United States from 1969 until 1986
appointed by Richard Nixon a man who
believed homosexual behavior could be
prohibited by law thought that sending a
man to prison for life for writing a bad
$100 check was just fine believed in a
strict constructionist reading of the
Constitution the Second Amendment does
not guarantee the right to have firearms
at all he said the excuses while the
excuses are hunting protection against
governmental tyranny and the rights of
the responsible gun owners bluntly if
you need 13 guns or an automatic weapon
of some kind to kill any animal smaller
than a Krakken you are no good at
hunting take up another pastime and
about protection against governmental
tyranny asked the interned
japanese-americans of world war ii how
well that idea worked and responsible
gun owners I'm sorry for them but at
this point seven gun terrorists have
committed seven gun massacres in the
last 37 days in this country this figure
does not include the nearly 10 percent
of all the presidents in our history
who've been
fascinated with guns nor a fifth who was
wounded nor the sixth who was wounded
while running for re-election nor seven
others who survived significant
assassination attempts by guns that's
thirteen out of the 44 presidents nearly
one-third of them
the BBC noted that in Christmas 2015 we
had 27 non suicide gun deaths in this
country for the entire year 2015
England had 24 such deaths responsible
gun ownership that ship sailed long ago
and Trump will actively or passively
call it back to port
to paraphrase professor Lawrence B
Hickok of Western Reserve College
speaking of slavery a century and a half
ago the question now before the American
citizens is no longer alone can the
schools and public places be made free
of the risk of gun massacres but are we
free or are we slaves under gun mob law
mob law in which the man seizing the
power of the government dog whistles to
that mob remember to bring your guns or
have the airline ship them for you
resist peace